الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يتحدث أو يتوقع أن يتحدث في
منتدى أعمال اليوم هو أحدث
ظهور رفيع المستوى حيث يعمل على
إعادة تأكيد سلطته بعد
تمرد نهاية الأسبوع الماضي من قبل مجموعة فاغنر أه
ورئيسهم يفغيني براغوسيان يوم
الأربعاء زار السيد بوتين
منطقة داغستان في الجنوب  روسيا ، حيث
رحب به أنصاره بحماس ، يقول الزعيم الروسي إنه لم
يشك أبدًا في دعم المواطنين الروس
خلال الانتفاضة ، بينما
ذكرت صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال أن يفغيني باغوسان
كان يخطط للقبض على وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويو والجنرال بالجيش
فاليري غاجميروف لكنه تخلى عن
الفكرة.  بعد أن اكتشف جهاز الأمن الفيدرالي الروسي ذلك
وقرر السير
في موسكو سينما ، كلير سيباستيان
بعد التطورات التي انضمت إلي هنا
في لندن ، كان هناك الكثير من الغموض
حول هذا في الوقت الذي نتعلم فيه
أكثر قليلاً ، أعتقد أننا استوعبنا
ذلك.  تقارير مختلفة
ولم نؤكدها ، لكن من
الواضح أن صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال تقول إن
FSB قد استوعبت منها وأن الاحتياطات
غيرت خططه وقد ذكرت صحيفة New York Times نقلاً
عن مسؤولين أمريكيين
مطلعين على المعلومات الاستخبارية قالوا نعم
في رتبة عالية جدًا  عام أه في
الجيش الروسي قد يكون القائد السابق
للعملية في أوكرانيا قد علم مسبقًا
بخطط مسبقة بالإضافة إلى
تقارير سي إن إن لدينا أن
المخابرات الأمريكية قد وضعت
صورة مفصلة إلى حد ما عما كان
يفعله التقدم أه لديك إحساس بأن الناس
كانوا  داخل روسيا وخارجها كنا على
دراية بطريقة ما بما كان يحدث
وربما إذا كان تقرير وول ستريت جورنال
صحيحًا والذي ساهم في
مستوى من الفوضى في الجانب
السابق لهذا الأمر ، أعتقد أن الشيء الرئيسي
الآن هو ذلك بالنسبة لـ  يعني هذا أن الكرملين
لا يزالون في
وضع التحكم في الضرر إلى حد كبير ، فقد رأيت تلك الصور
لبوتين في داغستان غير معتادة جدًا بالنسبة له
أن يكون خارجًا بين الحشود في أكمام
قميصه وربما بعض
البرامج المضادة للدعم الذي رأيناه
لفاغنر في روستوف  أنت تعرف هذا النوع من
الدعم الشعبي أثناء مغادرتهم المدينة ،
أعتقد أنه من الواضح أن الكرملين الآن
مضطر إلى تهدئة الشائعات حول
وجود تواطؤ في الرتب العليا في
الجيش أه مع ما كان البراغودي
يخطط للطرد الجنائي وهو
تكهنات و  القيل والقال وأيضًا
القلق من أن الحذر قد
يتمتع ببعض الشعبية ويمكن أن
يستمر ذلك في تقويض بوتين ، لذا فهم
بالتأكيد يتعاملون مع الكثير في
الوقت الحالي وأعتقد أنه من الواضح أنهم
لم ينتهوا ولم ينتهوا من البحث عن
نوع من الانتقام من أجل  ما
يحدث لا كلير شكرا لك